bachelor in paradise that's the only Oh
last time oh man what what oh man oh man
I might give me the give me the scoop
brother I'm here to spiel so before we
even go further and everyone thinking
I'm about to rant about The Bachelor I
might be I might be crossing into your
camp dude about how this is garbage TV
and I hate it I may have turned butt but
there's a different it's a different
thing because I hated enough to not
watch it no I I may have crossed that
threshold last night with bachelor in
paradise
just all of it I thought that one was
better though no okay
no oh man first off JPJ oh yeah John
Paul Jones he [ __ ] dm's me somebody
asked me to do my best impression of him
okay and this fool is just so guys
literally it that's funny I'm assuming
nobody was laughing to begin with he
just comes into a conversation like that
yeah yeah you good man yeah no I mean so
is he on the show right now yeah
so then how the [ __ ] did he DM me I mean
I think it's done okay so they they
shoot it yeah it's not like well violin
where it's like live no okay no I think
it's been done okay yeah that's
basically how that dude talks yeah you
got oh man I believe it was him he said
the dumbest [ __ ] possible what'd he say
he's like talking this black girl and he
was like you're like Beyonce but you
just have like bigger eyes and I'm like
is Beyonce the only black chick you've
seen yeah I don't have to hire like it's
definitely what it is dumb [ __ ] idiot
yeah the girl he was talking to look
nothing like Beyonce - her skin one of
you [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] right me Jesus Christ I could
not believe that like my jaw hit the
floor I'm like he's actually a [ __ ]
like to the hi what
[Music]
that's kind of funny that's like what
would that the other way around be what
like like just to some white girl oh
yeah you look like Taylor Swift your sin
Dunst yeah what is like some random @y
fit what I just went for popstar I'm
about to get [ __ ] crucified for
compared Beyonce to Taylor Swift
although apparently her new albums [ __ ]
dude this is crazy man Taylor Swift's
new album yeah was our like a day after
it released was already the biggest
album release of the year is get outta
here like for the week it was like they
sold two million copies overnight or
something how [ __ ] crazy is that her
fan base is another level note it's all
it's all cuz of tick tock what do you
mean no I say Jesus tick tock of what I
mean like I would be surprised if that
was the case you think her songs are on
tick tock
no I think I think it's like now I think
it's legitimately what bands yeah I
don't think anyone on take talk is I
don't think Jen's E is a fan of Taylor
Swift no I feel like it's like
Millennials t-swift
actually now that's not true we won't
went to her show it was like hella
little kids yeah ten lines of old people
do she uh whatever [ __ ] he swiftly and
everytime I her I don't even like that I
gave her a nickname like that even yeah
way keep going yeah so bachelor paradise
man first off you know that shit's
changing when ABC conservative asks
reality TV starts like trying to virtue
signal it's crazy they uh so this this
dude Dean he came on a few seasons ago
and he was like this clean-cut dapper
dude Dean Dean II ain't ain't my name's
dang
he came into the show like all dapper
and clean-cut Oh Debbie deemed epidemia
ad budding you David Dini window it I
can't even what the [ __ ] was that and I
was gonna like say something really
found and I just I I II mighty steep a
day that's what I call my penis right as
I'm about what are you doing
oh you might is that big a damper Dean's
pulling up my oh yeah drop the trap I'm
gonna [ __ ] your here and I'm gonna [ __ ]
your cons you can't scream it IM eiders
dep again better do it to step into you
wallaby yeah yeah yeah about a throw a
shrimp on your Bobby a little dance
waving your dick in the air but oh yeah
get off my shrimp yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] a
little Joey and yeah am i oh you should
so [ __ ] stupid ass show calm it's full
Dean he like he came to the show all
clean and he was like afraid to
introduce the girl Rachel to his dad
because he was like he's like a Hari
Krishna or something and like he used to
be David but now he's like you know he's
got like like a Swami name like it's
like a Indian surname and and he he he's
just like off the rails in terms of like
spirituality like lives and like butt
[ __ ] nowhere and
and so he was like clown and his dad for
being like this like weird spiritual
free spirit dude this season this fools
got his hair grown out he's living out
of a van this is Dean yeah I got a
[ __ ] yeah he got a serial killer
mustache from the 80s and he just like
he's the coldest most savage like he's
like he's chatting up this girl the
whole season he's got her she's a
[ __ ] you know plain-jane ass chick
sort of like so by-the-book and and like
he just dropped a bomb on her like in
the middle of the show he's like I don't
think he's like this is yeah this
obviously isn't gonna work after this
cuz like I live in a van and like I
don't want to spend my life like going
to dinner parties and talking about her
feelings like hey that's boring he's
like he's like a van life dude yeah yeah
Instagram dude yeah their life van life
but honestly so stupid I put like I
honestly think that it's it's some type
of weird I don't know I have like this
jaded look at all the bachelor people
like everything they do is some ww-what
the hell go ahead say it
go ahead must have found my mixtape yeah
there you go Thanks ya know I feel like
everything they do is like some WWF like
scripted like alright you're gonna turn
into this dude because then we're gonna
bring you back for this season and they
were like I feel like the producers are
involved in all that [ __ ] cuz like
you look at like his van life pictures
and it's not a typical van life dude
like they're all like professional shots
of him shirtless that's this is what I'm
talking about this van life [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] stupid because it's like it's
like they really are way more vain than
anyone else like their weight they're
way more concerned with like appearances
then then people that just live in
cities yeah you know I'm saying a little
bit if you ever see one of these [ __ ]
van life is good a search hashtag van
life yeah it's like they're all like
that it's all like perfet like at least
one person in the van is a photographer
it's usually a couple mm-hmm and oh
you're talking about that kind of Van
Lines yeah where they like convert a
little van to whatever
and then they just they just make people
envious of that life yeah their sole
goals like drive around to beautiful
places and all their pictures take a
picture the sunset the guy and a dog
laying on the bed and it's like hashtag
Van Lines like no but you don't you see
how contradicting this is yeah and then
they they all finger wag you about how
living in your big house and all that
urban City is not necessary and you
should be more in touch with nature that
should be more in touch with nature oh
you take pictures of your girl it's at a
[ __ ] yeah exactly at a van rest stop
people [ __ ] taking the subway every
day yeah yeah you know saying like
people that live in cities they probably
use less waste and they're [ __ ] no
distributing yeah yeah no no no so okay
I think there's a split what the [ __ ] is
that now AC nah so uh somebody just
fired up their props drill or some [ __ ]
yeah that's uh that's Ronnie Jay he's
downstairs he's cooking up in you 8:08
okay so I have to say real quick van
life people follow two categories for me
there's that van life where it's just
hot people being [ __ ] mm-hmm and
then there's the other van life for its
like rock climbers that have like two
posts oh yeah yeah it's truly about yeah
yeah because they don't give a [ __ ]
about it yeah yeah yeah that's why you
don't see that [ __ ] yeah it's just like
a pot the first picture the second
picture is like mountain that's like
sick and that's it
about that about to climb this yeah van
life and that's it and that's it and
then you're like did they fall off the
bed or another four years later you'll
send an update of like his shoe yeah
need some new ones yeah yeah that's
that's like my friend he bought a he
bought this giant Sprinter uh-huh and
converted it over like the course of
like six seven months it was like it's
bone personal project yeah got a bunch
of money converting this van into this
like beautiful [ __ ] house that he
could drive anywhere yeah and he just
[ __ ] drives around surfs climbs
mountains yeah it is crazy ass [ __ ] yeah
so every once in a while he'll throw
some [ __ ] up on a story and it's like
but he's not like no no he's not like
the overly visco filtered and images and
know he just really loves that life it's
crazy
so yeah his whole van life [ __ ] is some
[ __ ] and so like I thought it was
funny that like they're trying to just
like I don't know like it to me felt
like them trying to break the like
conservative stereotype of all the
people on that show like oh I the
contestants aren't all [ __ ] boring
religious people uh look at Dean he
lives in a van and there's a gypsy he's
a gypsy which is something you can't say
but gypsy yeah you can't say gypsy yeah
that's that's a bad one Nick you can say
it no no you can you really can't
that's a slur yeah it is no way it's a
slur yeah yeah the Maya
Elena's cousins tell me about this okay
what she was saying or he was telling me
that the proper term is it's something
like the traveling community that's what
it is it's traveling community I know
you didn't mean it that way you
definitely didn't mean it that way this
is like obscure like UK knowledge that I
have [ __ ] while normally considered a
racial slur yes there you go the word
gypsy in the u.s. refers to a person of
a Romani heritage so there you go I'm
I'm safe sort of I'm gonna give you the
passes that you meant that in the in the
Hunchback of Notre I just mean like a
traveling yeah yeah yeah yeah just like
a nomad yeah anyway yeah look at look at
Dean look at Dean yeah oh yeah he's a
[Laughter]
Dane yeah he's a free kind of spirit
look at him in his six-pack in his van
he lives in a van yeah travelling freely
all around the states with a
photographer yeah [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of everybody
yeah so that's
reading chlamydia brothel and that to me
was like [ __ ] out of here she's all
crying and I was like dying laughing at
this she's like yeah that guy in the van
wouldn't wanna be in a long-term
relationship I just don't get it
mmm whatever the thing that was really
goofy was there's a girl on the show who
I guess is by and in the middle of a
show apparently she says I'm this is I
could not believe that she goes I'm not
sure if I like the guy that I'm dating
on the show because I'm dating a girl
outside the show and then they bring
this random girl who's not even part of
the show to the show so that they have
this goofy rose ceremony where they have
her go first and she gives a rose to
this random girl that they brought on
the show so now I guess she's part of
the show it's like this so that's some
love island [ __ ] they're taking a page
out of Lowe Allen's book maybe but it
just felt bad like it like it was so
shoehorned and I'm like dude nobody gay
or anything like anyone for I feel like
watches the show like on ironically yeah
I'm saying yeah I feel like people who
truly enjoy bachelor in paradise like
are like moms mm-hmm and everyone else
thinks it's just so [ __ ] stupid
yeah so to me I'm like who are you
virtue signaling for yeah like just just
keep it you're goofy crazy blonde chicks
and stupid guys mm-hmm I didn't I mean
whatever maybe it's a good thing that
they're trying to switch it up I don't
know but yeah it felt like I feel like
some goofy ass fake [ __ ] hmm like that
it also is pretty um it also is pretty
like WWE that's what I mean is bringing
in a random kara I'm één its Tiana she's
gonna eat [ __ ] and suck dick I'm here
to eat [ __ ] and subducting oh hey I
don't care I don't care what you think
about that cut to David oh I'm really
scared that you know
gonna take my girl because she's so
stick and eats [ __ ] she sucks [ __ ] and
eats dick dude I wish she just came in
[ __ ] you'll never know what I'll do
I'll suck a dick and eat some [ __ ] in
the same day I'm crazy
every [ __ ] suburban mom is like oh yo
my goodness Brittany did you see last
night did you see last night I could not
believe what that woman was saying that
woman eats vagina horrible in the same
day I always I always I always say that
[ __ ] is WWF for like it really it really
just sent me over the top but here's the
thing that pushed me to like [ __ ] this
show hmm [ __ ] this show they took two
people from previous season two
goofballs and they're getting married on
this season's televised marriage or
whatever then they put people as
bridesmaids and groomsmen and [ __ ] to
purposefully milk drama yeah and like
stir up old [ __ ] and get these
stupid-ass people being like move your
leg to grew into woody and our just like
maybe I like the Grund wedding I don't
know I don't know I thought I like the
girl in front of you know it's like
people who's like come on how are you
this stupid how like all they have to do
is see their ex and they're falling in
love again that's good yeah and so then
they have like like people crying at the
wedding and I'm like you're these shitty
people making this wedding about
themselves yeah this goddamn show damn
so what are you retired now I might be
man yeah it legitimately pissed me off
Wow how'd you just getting super [ __ ]
hey I know what grown man 3 hey Singh
around your living room at the best
bachelor in paradise just a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah I can't wait to talk about
this tomorrow
half an hour yeah yeah I did exactly
what they wanted me to do and I did
exactly what every guy in their late
teenage years does yeah gets really mad
about the bachelor and talks about on
this podcast exactly yeah
what about this dude what about Dan life
that dude's name Dan ah just hashtag and
Dan life on everything yeah it's just
living yeah you know yeah Dan life it's
Dan life your name is Dan I want to see
throw that hashtag up on Instagram I'm
gonna be searching it all right just do
[ __ ] normal [ __ ] go to your job
eat your sandwich but take a picture of
sandwich and hashtag it dan life another
cold one out of the water cooler here
hashtag Dan life sip in a cold brew
hashtag Dan life once with mom
hashtag Dan life I'm saying about that
damn life yeah she's the one who made
this damn life it has to be I really
need a parody The Bachelor but it has to
be that way yeah like in the middle of a
really romantic moment that's just all
you hear yeah and then crazy bisexual
just gonna punching through the wall
yeah that's a great idea it's just a
dude I do you previously thought was
straight uh-huh I actually have to tell
you something I'm bi as well and they
start making out she's like another girl
she's like I have to tell you something
too and then just everyone on the show
by that's their trope everyone on the
show it's called bachelor in paradise
and by bachelors in paradise and then
there's just John Paul Jones on the side
[Music]
thugs like Kermit why did he do it why
did he dam me let's see what he said
let's see what JPJ said to me I don't
know who he was and then I was like I
looked at this thing I'm like damn he's
[ __ ] oh man dude this is gonna be the
meanest way for him to find out what
that may be yeah he's gonna watch that
whole [ __ ] John Paul by the way some
of y'all are asking if we're ever gonna
move out of this storage closet or
repaint it and the answer is yes and I
believe all the changes will take place
just in time for episode 100 is it dude
I love your videos man let me know if
you want to collab sometime and then I
looked like I was like we want his page
I was like [ __ ] is this dude it's like a
thousand comments on every picture I
told Kelsey and she was like oh my god
that guy's from The Bachelor he's got
some [ __ ] flow though dude you got
some hair on your brother yeah yeah yeah
keep that out dude yeah that's great
that's right
not about it I don't know what we'd
collab on those the only thing what kind
of videos are we thinking I don't know
maybe we can have them on we're gonna
have like um we're gonna have like a
little bench yeah guess yeah so maybe
we'll start dabbling with bringing
bringing some guests on just just some
quick sec we ease into it you know it's
a quick quick 15 20 minute segments
that's what I'm thinking yeah I'm
Hobson's for a baby not it'd be kind of
funny cool yeah have him on yeah a
little bachelor in paradise yeah I
definitely own up to everything I just
said though what do you mean like I do
the impression in front him yeah I mean
he probably knows you think I mean like
Kelsey was like oh my god he's like the
goofiest dude ever that's the other
thing is I don't know you can never tell
what the bachelor editing how how candid
any of those moments are yeah exactly he
could it just to find out maybe they
just took all the moments where he's
laughing and the editors like I'm gonna
make this guy look like such a [ __ ]
cuts them together from yeah yeah yeah
so just laughing for like 30 seconds
[Music]
sitting there thinking what the [ __ ] I
just chuckles like a second I wasn't
laughing that long I don't even sound
like
[Music]